give new prices right in Cleveland I
would loved it with that I hate I hate
Los Angeles no city can exist without
people and Cleveland has lost more than
half its population since the 1950s when
nearly a million people lived in the
city many moved to nearby suburbs but
even so the population in the region has
remained flat for decades given all of
its problems you might wonder why anyone
would want to live in Cleveland well for
one thing Clevelanders enjoy the kinds
of big-ticket entertainment options you
can only find in large cities in
addition to the Browns Cavaliers and
Indians and attractions like the Rock
and Roll Hall of Fame Cleveland has a
lot to offer people with a taste for
high culture the Columbia and we have a
tremendous Orchestra playoffs where is
the largest contiguous in these cultural
attractions are great but can they
really do anything to help revitalize
Cleveland we get it wrong we think that
it's the cultural amenities that drive
the prosperity but really it's the
prosperity that drives the cultural
management it's true the orchestra
museum and theaters in Cleveland are
artifacts of an era when Cleveland was
an industrial powerhouse and throw off
tons of cash the Rock and Roll Hall of
Fame in the Sports Complex is on the
other hand were built with hundreds of
millions of taxpayer dollars and
sweetheart deals during Cleveland's
economic decline these amenities are not
the fruits of a vibrant economy their
monuments to the empty promises of
Cleveland politicians and while the
Cavaliers provide a great entertainment
option for tourists from the suburbs you
can't judge a city's health by looking
at its basketball team
I mean LeBron James is not going to save
Cleveland so what else does Cleveland
have going for it well there's no
denying that many people absolutely love
the city in fact we found some
interesting folks who were so charmed by
Cleveland that they decided to move here
in a past life les Roberts was a
Hollywood producer and writer for shows
like the Hollywood Squares in the Lucy
show he came to Cleveland for the first
time in 1987 and I didn't know anything
about Cleveland
I knew about Jim Brown and Bob Feller
and the river burning I had no I had no
clue what the city was all about here
and I absolutely I was here for like 10
days and I fell in love it's Cleveland
let's move to Cleveland a few years
later and has been writing novels
featuring cleveland-based detective
Milan Djokovic ever since tajmahal age a
professional BMX rider who's lived in
Austin for the past 15 years recently
decided to relocate completely from the
first time I came here I got this really
strong feeling that this could be home
and it's a cool place so what exactly is
so cool about Cleveland we ask the best
experts we could find the people who
live here we're right on the lake we
have great landscapes we have great
architecture leave is a small detail big
enough so everybody has a mill your
business gets small enough so you still
have friends it's a great place to raise
a family really is Cleveland is also an
incredibly affordable place to live
because really you work 20 hours a week
in Cleveland you pay around you have a
lot of time to do your art and your
space - what - homebuyers get for their
money in Cleveland
we asked 80 Brailler a local real estate
in front of a beautiful home in
Cleveland Ohio
this house has beautiful hardwood
flooring beautiful kitchen four bedroom
it's only 132 thousand dollars that's a
lot of house for the money but for
Clevelanders willing to take a risk and
do some major renovations they're
virtually giving the houses away I'd
like to show you a home that is $8,400
great investors dream right here and
young professionals in Cleveland can get
a really great downtown condo at a price
that will make people who live in other
big cities green with envy we're in the
common area right now which is just
gorgeous so I'm going to send you up to
a unit that's a two-bedroom two-bath
that's two hundred seventy nine nine
it's a little over twelve hundred square
feet it's got granite it's got stainless
steel hardwood flooring and great views
Cleveland's also a diverse city with
lots of great ethnic neighborhoods the
people who live in these neighborhoods
are the descendants of immigrants who
originally came to Cleveland when the
economy was thriving and he's a weekend
in the summer you can throw a rock and
hit two different you know the Polka
festival of the neighborhoods I love the
people I love the the food the
restaurants Clevelanders looking for
live music can find cool jazz at the
nighttime jazz club on the east side and
great blues and a working-class ride at
the Parkview night club on the west side
of town tell us about the party night
club what's the history of park
lot of history this bars been around
since Prohibition and before this whole
neighborhood is littered with
speakeasies the remains of speakeasy so
this this bar was in a kind of a crazy
neighborhood one of our favorite joints
at Cleveland is a one of a kind place
called the velvet tango room you're at
the velvet tango room which is a very
unique cocktail lounge in Cleveland and
the the mission of the velvet tango room
is to keep alive burning bright the
flame of cocktail culture classic
cocktails not cocktails that taste like
gummy bears were the torch bearers of of
what a classic cocktail should be
Cleveland also has hidden gems like
raised indoor mountain bike park the
only one of its kind in the whole world
it was a dream of mine for years and
then I had an opportunity and I found
some space just threw the dice spent my
life savings since the first time I've
come here arrays has been what I think
just is the happiest place on bikes that
I've ever been around
everyone's riding up three old kids old
man and moms pros it's great it's really
worked out really well and it's all
about just having fun and as anyone
who's visited Cleveland will tell you
Clevelanders are very good people
I'll tell you like it is and they have a
good time Clevelanders certainly know
how to have a good time on st. Patrick's
but when the party's over the city
empties out again are there any signs of
a turnaround not really in fact
according to a recent study 60% of
Ohio's college students plan to leave
the state when they graduate many of
them will move to cities like Houston
when you look at Euston you say why do
people go there well they don't go for
the topography they don't go for the
climate they go to Euston for
opportunity that's what it's all about
all great cities are aspirational they
are places where people go because
things could be better for them I would
like everybody in Cleveland to have like
rich kid syndrome but they feel guilty
you know that they had all these
opportunities and they have to go to
Nicaragua now to do some work in the
summer when they're off from college to
make up for it in order to compete with
other cities Cleveland must deal with
its most fundamental issues for starters
the city needs to fix the schools make
government more efficient and create a
more business friendly environment I
think the city could be conceivably a
lot better but I think it's gonna have
to let go a lot of a lot of its older
dysfunctional ideas this is one of the
problems that almost all these old
industrial cities have had a very
concentrated decision-making process
very bureaucratic well I think one thing
that the city needs to do is is is back
off a little bit and recognize that that
real sustainable economic development
has to be organic and has to occur
bottom-up at the end of the day city
officials need to let go of their
bureaucratic inclinations and find ways
to make Cleveland the kind of city where
people are free to pursue their own
versions of the American dream it reads
to be a freer city than it is today
it'll work out on its own I'm telling
you that Adam Smith invisible hand is a
really good thing there's nothing to be
afraid of
it was
you got a bit
you